welcome back to Long Prime Deli
everybody we have a big update for you
in the death of a Florida Microsoft
executive targeted in a hit last year
his ex-wife is now facing charges so we
want to lay out all the players that are
involved in this so Jared bride again
was married to Shanna Gardner but the
two divorced Shanna married Mariel
Saldana Fernandez investigators say that
Fernandez plotted with a man named Henry
tennen to kill bride again tennan was a
tenant and one of Fernandez's
Fernandez's rental properties and when
he was arrested he admitted what he'd
done and told police that he would
cooperate with them police say Jared
bride again had just dropped off his
twins at shanna's home in Jacksonville
Beach Florida and he was headed back to
his own place with his two-year-old from
his second marriage in the car when he
came across a tire in the road when he
got out to move it police say tenants
shot him Shannon moved across the
country to Washington after the murder
distancing herself from her new husband
but Thursday morning a grand jury handed
down an indictment against her
prosecutors also made a stunning
announcement about punishment they're
seeking
a fourth circuit grand jury indicted
Shanna Gardner her first degree murder
conspiracy to commit first degree murder
solicitation to commit first degree
murder and child abuse all related to
the murder of Jared Breton Shannon's
ex-husband
Gardner was arrested shortly after and
taken into custody by ATF Washington
field division agents in West Richland
Washington
Gardner will be extradited to Duval
County to face these charges
we will be filing a notice of our intent
to seek the death penalty as we have
also done in the case of Mario Fernandez
okay so the prosecution is now seeking
the death penalty against Gardner and
Fernandez good idea to go after the to
go that penalty for both of them I think
so I would do either both of them or
neither of them because in my opinion if
she is the one who said look I want to
kill my ex-husband and she engaged her
current husband to do that they're both
responsible they're both plotting
against him and so I do think if you
think that this is a death penalty case
as a prosecutor I would do it against
both of them now I think the person who
actually pulled a trigger tenant because
he actually admitted to it and he pulled
the trigger and he went to the police I
wouldn't put the death penalty against
him and there's no evidence that they
are doing that well he's cooperating
correct right exactly so but I do think
that they should seek it against both of
them here's the thing I don't get they
were a bit tight-lipped on what new
information they gained uh that
ultimately led to this grand jury
indictment the fact that they're going
with a death penalty does that tell us
something Ryan does that give us some
Clues as to what may have happened here
I think it does I think whatever they
found in terms of presenting to the
grand jury is going to be jaw-dropping
because if tenant is the is the trigger
man why seek the death penalty for these
two who did the planning and not the
actual trigger man we've seen it the
other way around in other cases think of
ymw Melly why they're seeking the death
penalty for him and not wanting to be
Portland so I think the planning of the
murders and what probably went into
getting uh Bryden to the location where
the murder happened I think might be so
heinous that's why they're seeking the
death money there I'm looking at
forensics text messages coordination
between the two of them and then it's
going to be jaw-dropping in this case so
I know we've seen cases before where the
killer themselves the jury comes back
and sent it to somebody to or recommends
the sentence of death for someone who
planned it and didn't pull the trigger
or actually stab someone or strangle
someone do we typically see a jury
voting in favor of the death penalty for
the planner well not usually but here I
think had it not been for the wife had
it not been for the current husband this
would not have happened and oftentimes I
say why not go after the people who
planned it why not have the death
penalty against them the person who
pulled the trigger in this case was just
someone who happened to be living in the
complex someone who may have had a gun
someone who may have you know been
involved in crimes before he was just
someone you know that they were using
essentially and it sounds to me the fact
that the child was in the car was an
aggravating factor that they can't
escape but that's aggravating it's
another charge that's the child that
discharged there good point that is a
chub but I think that adds an extra
layer to it as well coming up on Long
crime daily Amazon dominates many retail
spaces and members of the publishing
world have had it a new letter asking
for an FTC probe and the ftc's own
efforts to loosen the company's iron
grip plus May Mark the one-year
anniversary of a deadly racially
motivated mass shooting out in New York
who the victims and their families are
now choosing to Target in two brand new
lawsuits
thank you
[Music]
welcome back everybody it has been a
little over a year since a racially
motivated mass shooting in Buffalo New
York and this week two new lawsuits are
being filed to try to hold those who
help the shooter accountable on May 14
2022 a gunman entered Tops Friendly
Market with an AR-15 killing 10 people
wounding three others and leaving a
community traumatized the shooting took
place in a predominantly black
neighborhood and all those who were
killed were black it was revealed that
the gunman was a self-proclaimed white
supremacist and the attack was
considered a hate crime in February of
this year the shooter was sentenced to
11 consecutive life sentences for murder
domestic terrorism and hate crimes
charges it also faces additional hate
crimes charges in federal court
Wednesday it was announced that two new
lawsuits are being filed against a
number of parties believed to be
responsible for the supermarket attack
the plaintiffs include the son of
Celestine Cheney who was killed in the
shooting in 16 survivors that continue
to suffer severe emotional distress
listed defendants include companies that
manufactured and sold the rifle magazine
lock and body armored of the gunman also
included are social media platforms
YouTube and Reddit which allegedly
helped radicalize the shooter and help
him learn all about weapons the suits
also Target the gunman's parents
claiming they ignored clear warning
sides of an imminent threat the
plaintiffs seek an undisclosed amount of
punitive and compensatory damages so
what do you think Terry do you think
this is a good lawsuit you think there's
something here about holding the people
that made the gun and distributed it
absolutely I think they are in New York
and that's a good thing as far as this
lawsuit is concerned because New York
has stricter laws then you might see
under federal law so for the gun
manufacturers under federal law they are
exempt unless there is some sort of
entrustment some negligent entrustment
they're exempt from any liability as far
as the manufacturing is concerned and so
in New York you can sue the manufacturer
because if it's a public nuisance you
can sue so they're in New York same
thing with the social media they're in
New York social media companies are
responsible in New York they have to
have policies to prevent these sort of
hate crimes under New York under New
York law they really do have a good
chance of prevailing in this under
federal law it's not the same under
Section 230 I know we're getting into
detail but under that section social
media companies are exempt unless
they're very special circumstances from
liability for these types of cases I
mean Brian what do you think this is not
the first time somebody has filed this
kind of lawsuit before yeah
unfortunately a lot of it failed but to
Terry's Point both New York and
California are creating new laws to try
to push back on that but I think not
only is opening the door to make it
available for them to make these type of
lawsuits well thing the finger pointing
that's going to happen is going to be
ridiculous because I I can already see
the the people who do the body armor are
going to say I didn't make a product
that killed anyone my my product
literally protects people so go after
the gun people the gun people say hey a
gun laying there on a table doesn't harm
anyone go after those social media who's
putting these ideas out there in the
social media platforms will be like I
didn't put a gun in anyone's hands it's
going to be like the Spider-Man meme
with them all pointing at each other and
I think not only the finger pointing but
also the law itself the issue of
causation I'm YouTube I have good videos
I have bad videos just because this
person decided to focus on the bad
videos I can't be held liable for that
it sounds like a lot of moving Parts
here it filed on the one year
anniversary that's pretty symbolic now
yeah it is it's symbolic I think they
want to make a point here and I think
I'm glad that they're bringing it and
one thing I have to say as far as what
Ryan's concerned point fingers if you
want there's plenty of blame to go
around and I think that you're seeing
States like New York and California
enforcing these sort of new laws so that
we can finally maybe do something as far
as these math students all right well
we'll continue to follow this one uh
when we come back Amazon finds
themselves in the hot seat or maybe more
than one why they're being accused of
monopolizing the book industry and a
move by the FTC that could disband them
for good
[Music]
and we are finishing Today's Show with a
letter written to the Department of
Justice about tech giant Amazon U.S
booksellers and authors want the online
retailer investigated over their alleged
Chokehold on the book selling industry
the author and Bookseller associations
are demanding a probe by the Federal
Trade Commission on Amazon's quote
continued use of unfair methods of
competition Amazon initially started out
as an online bookstore in 1994 and
according to the letter they now account
for 50 to 90 percent of all physical and
e-book sales and the retail and online
space the groups accuse Amazon of using
quote strong arm tactics to force
traditional publisher Publishers to sign
oppressive contracts they'll let Amazon
to market the products in ways that best
benefit the company now behind the
scenes it's reported that Amazon is
scheduled to have one last meeting with
the FTC before the agency launches a
massive Anti-Trust lawsuit that could
disband the company for good now the
majority of the ftc's lawsuit allegedly
tackles Logistics Monopoly claims so
it's unclear if Book Sales in particular
are included in that conversation
Terry this is pretty big I mean Amazon
here what is your take on it well first
of all Amazon is very convenient I think
a lot of people would be very upset if
Amazon somehow was disband but you can
have a dominance in the market without
being a Monopoly without violating
Anti-Trust laws to violate antitrust
laws what you have to do is things like
price fixing that you are unfairly
competing here if Amazon can show look
we're just good we just make sure we get
our products out and we you know
distribute them well and we're doing it
on time just because they're good and
they have a large piece of the market
doesn't mean that they're violating the
law so you are a published author Brian
I don't know if you have a bias in this
case but what's your take on it the
authors seem what's their argument yeah
so the argument being that this is a
monopoly they don't have the ability to
push these sales of their books or the
prices the way they want and I I don't
think I've seen anything with my own
book come home and say but I have talked
to my Publishers on some days I see the
book going first full price in other
days I see it going for half off and
then 25 and then it's like these weird
sales that go on and I do ask questions
and they say well it's just the
algorithm that Amazon uses to help
promote their books I'm like all right
so how is it helping my book for me I
think it's a lot of just the mystery of
not knowing and not fully understanding
and I think that's where the question
becomes if there are smoke is there fire
now Amazon I like having my book there
please do not pull it based on this I'm
just saying that I understand the
arguments and the smoke and mirrors of
like people asking questions and I say
hey FTC can you look into this because
we've got some questions yeah Ryan's
book is now available at Borders it's
gone uh but let me ask you this Amazon's
not going to get the span you know for
this right no I mean it most they might
have to change some of their practices
but I don't think that anyone at least
based on what I've seen is going to be
able to show that they intentionally
you'll have to have emails you'll have
to have documentation that they said
look I know that borders is in this
market let's go after them let's
undercut their prices
exactly if you have evidence like that
then in fact you can all right top it
for another day Terry Brian thank you
everyone thanks for joining us here on
Long crime daily we're going to see you
next time as we discuss Justice in
America